[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up Roth
good day Walter good day I see we've
swapped shirts today yes I wanted to
sell the people I also have sets like
you have ways to share them I just like
you excellent excellent
I'm a really father we thank you so much
for the opportunity to come back
together again we ask that you lead the
way with the Holy Spirit and guide us in
everything that we learn in Jesus name
Amen amen
so we've been discussing what of a lot
about the second coming the signs and
all of this there's some confusion I
think about some of it there's some fear
that people have what do you have do you
have to do can I be saved will I be
ready
will you maybe discuss and teach us a
little bit more what the Bible teaches
on we are waiting in this stage you know
basically it always comes down to the
character of God if you have a wrong
concept of the character of God then
fear will always be a factor in the
Middle Ages fear was the driving force
of the religious system and then the
Protestant Reformation came and took it
to the other extreme and then we have to
sort of get back to a median part but
the character of God is absolutely
critical how do you see God do you see
God as this hard taskmaster or do you
see God as a loving kind compassion
comforting God and how far do you go
along that I always like to quote Exodus
34 verses 6 & 7 where Moses asked that
he should see God and God said if you
see my face then you will not survive
it's like the brilliance of the Sun to
the times 10 so it reads there and the
Lord passed by before him and proclaimed
the Lord the Lord God merciful gracious
long-suffering abundant in goodness and
truth those are the attributes of God
and then this promise keeping mercy for
thousands forgiving iniquity and
transgression and sin and that will by
no means clear the guilty so you have
this beautiful balance between
graciousness and kindness and compassion
and justice yes the two work together
you you cannot divorce the one from the
other if you put too much emphasis on
the justice then you have a harsh
taskmaster that cannot wait to chop your
head off for whatever your indiscretions
are but if you mingle the two and
justice and mercy kissed each other at
the cross they demonstrated God's
justice but they also general absolutely
demonstrated his mercy and His
forgiveness the most interesting
addition visiting the iniquity of the
father's upon the children and upon the
children's children unto the third and
to the fourth generation now that
confuses many people does that mean
I mean God very clearly in His Word says
that the iniquity of the fathers may not
be transferred to the children and the
other
is also taboo yes so what does it mean
when he says visiting the iniquity of
the father's upon the children and upon
the children's children unto the third
and fourth generation now as a scientist
I studied genetics of course and then a
relatively recent development in
genetics is the science of epigenetics
and this shows that inherited tendencies
and not just the genetic blueprint of
what you are taught was a transfer from
one generation to another so not just
the hard core DNA but also the life
experience and the attitudes are
transferred via the epi genes to make it
simple we don't want to go into a
science lecture now I have some lectures
on it in the genetics lecture people can
look at those if they wanted but to put
it simply your genes or your hardware
and your epigenetics is the software and
the to work together and when there is
transfer of genes to the next generation
it's not only the hardware but the
software that is transferred as well so
if you have inherited tendencies
whatever they may be
there can be dietary they can be moved
you are a very angry person with these
these anger hormones in your body all
the time
then your genetic presupposition is
likely to be transferred to the next
generation and I say that it takes about
three or four generations to get rid of
this epigenetic transfer so this is a
beautiful scientific statement actually
so he's not saying that he's going to
punish the next generation he's saying
that the inherited tendencies will be
perpetuated and if you if you start if
your families
struggling with one particular thing
then that is something that you must
guard again let's say it's anger yeah
then the next generation must must work
harder at that particular point but it
could be a dietary thing that leads to
cancer yeah that means if you have a
propensity in the family let's say
towards breast cancer that people have
to take dietary well behavioral
strategies to counteract that more so
than those that don't have yes those
tendencies so that's what he's basically
saying he's saying I'm a merciful God
I'm the kind God I'm a forgiving God but
that doesn't mean that I'm not a God of
justice I'm a God of justice as well and
the two have to be be in harmony so if
you have transgressions if you have
sinned they come to me and let's reason
together and I'll forgive you and I'll
impress you and I'll help you and then
we'll we'll work at it and bring you
back into harmony with God's
requirements that's what what the verse
means so it's very beautiful so people
that are afraid overemphasize one of the
attributes of God and people that are
lackaday zio overemphasize the other
attribute of God but you have to have
them
I think what's beautiful for media is
that you actually used Old Testament
scripture to show the beauty of God
where a lot of people will say that God
of the Old Testament is this wrathful
tyrant yes and the New Testament God is
a loving one but here you just showed us
that it's their birthday yes now if you
take the New Testament God portrayal in
in Jesus Christ where this is God
manifest in the flesh
how did he demonstrate his justice by
paying the price the wages of sin is
death
death and God's justice demanded the
death sentence and in Christ everybody
can be saved because corporately all of
humanity was in Christ when he died on
that cross because he being God had all
of humanity in him that's why only God
could have paid that price and nobody
else yes that is beautiful
so can you take us a little bit further
because what you've been discussing also
in the previous ones is Matthew 24 and
we've been in for them focusing a lot on
that yeah that's not the only part
portions in the Bible that know so we've
been focusing a lot of Matthew 24 and
we've gone through many of those issues
but you know there's also a Matthew 22
and there's a Matthew 25 and for those
people that have fears about if Christ
should return am I ready hmm there's
this beautiful parable that Jesus gives
in Matthew 22 on the kingdom of heaven
is like unto a certain King which made a
marriage for his son so here is the the
marriage ceremony and it tells the story
about the indication that goes out to
everyone to come to this great event now
remember in the olden days the marriage
took place and that wasn't the actual
ceremony where the husband and the wife
came together right where the two
parties came together that something
that took place before so this is this
invitation and then finally he comes to
the point where he says to his servants
the wedding is ready and but they that
were bidden were not worthy because many
refused to come I'm busy with this are
busy with that go ye therefore into the
highways and as many as you shall find
bid to the marriage now you have this
this pick
everywhere in the Bible God sends out
the blanket invitation but not everybody
is in tune with God so some come to the
invitation for the bread and the fishes
the loaves and the fishes some come for
whatever reason some come out of
curiosity some come to say I was there I
was there but how serious are you about
this invitation and the invitation is
not only to the elite the elite have the
invitation but it goes to the highways
and byways and so the servants went out
into the highways and gathered together
as many as they found both bad and good
you know you have the the wheat and the
tares yes so people always expect you
know you're gonna go to church and
you're gonna find these absolutely
marvelous perfect people in the church
and what a pleasant surprise right when
you find out well I'm being a little bit
facetious they're not so pleasant
surprise you might find that it's not so
it's not so even if you look at your own
character you say - okay so there's
other people like me as well
[Laughter]
absolutely okay so those Evans went out
into the highway and they gathered
together all as many as they found both
bad and good the wheat and the tares
growing together and the wedding was
furnished with guests that's a beautiful
explanation of the church yeah they're
all sitting and you know you might have
an attribute that irritates person a and
person B here doesn't have a problem
with that attitude so we're gonna it's
like a family you rub up against each
other and when the king came in to see
the guests he saw there a man which had
not a wedding garment this is a very
important part of scripture and he said
unto him
and I like this friend miss this this is
how God is so he knew this man because
he called him a friend and when you eat
with someone yeah you're a friend right
so this is the person that was in the
church but he didn't have a wedding
garment on and he said unto Him friend
how camest the in hither not having a
wedding common and he was speechless
then said the King to the servants bind
him hand and foot and take him away and
caused him into outer darkness it's
interesting that says outer darkness
okay so you have those that are in a
relationship of those that aren't really
and there shall be weeping and gnashing
of teeth for many are called but few are
chosen and that has nothing to do with
selection it has to do with your choice
now why was this friend in trouble
because it occurs the comment with what
comment did he have on him but he was
dressed obviously wasn't naked so what
comment did he have on he had the
comment of his own righteousness hmm and
this is where people make a mistake and
this was the beauty of the Reformation
the Reformation put into center stage
the righteousness of crisis
justification by faith justification by
faith is such a astoundingly beautiful
doctrine there is nothing as powerful as
justification by faith it means I do not
get saved because of my own
righteousness I get saved because of his
beautiful righteousness his seamless
robe of righteousness the symbolism in
the Bible is just a living man his rope
was seamless it was it was woven in a
heavenly loom
so here's this the seamless robe of
righteousness with not one spot or one
wrinkle in it and it covers you but if
you come there with your own
righteousness then you have no chance
you will end up outside because your own
righteousness will not stand up to the
scrutiny of God in terms of justice in
terms of his broken law yes so never
ever can I say I am saved by my good
works or because I'm a wonderful person
or because I haven't done this or I
haven't done that the wages of sin is
death these low body that hasn't sinned
no matter how sweet they are there's
nobody that hasn't sinned miss doesn't
the Bible say yep all have sinned and
fall short of the glory of God and
neither says he's without sin as a liar
so what does it take to get hold of that
road you have to come to God what shall
we do to be saved the first word out of
Peters mouth was really picked yes right
other words turn around say okay I
acknowledge I have this problem and now
I'm stripped of my importance and my
robe I'm naked
so cover me with your righteousness and
this is an imputed righteousness it is
an alien righteousness it's not a
righteousness that is my own it is a
righteousness that is his and it is a
juridical proclamation in other words it
is a legal proclamation you are declared
righteous in his righteousness not your
own
so his righteousness covers you so the
thief on the cross he could only qualify
for this yes then of course you have
this nice theological
after that comes imparted righteousness
that is a process where through trial
and error and stumbling and striving to
enter into the narrow gate God imparts
his character elements to you so if you
were a mean miserly person you become
kinder and less miserly and it's a
growth process so how afraid do I have
to be of God if I understand this
character if I know that I'm in the
wrong do I have to say to him
I need another five weeks in order to
get this thing sorted or do I have to
break and say I'm guilty I was wrong
forgive me help me to be nicer help me
to be kinder and God gives you his
righteousness from that moment you are
perfect
through his justifications justice that
should take away fear yes your your
picture of God if your picture of God is
one false step and you go to hell
Calvinism Methodism for example Wesley
said the difference between the
approaches is your view of God
do you see God as this all-powerful
ruler who will have his will be done no
matter what or do you see God as this
kind merciful loving father and he uses
the Lord's Prayer and he says it says
our Father which art in heaven hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done on earth as it is in heaven
or do you see God as our ruler who is in
heaven Hallowed be your name your will
be done on earth as it is in heaven but
all right he is a powerful ruling but
what is your concept of God and if we
can get that right then a lot of fear
should just disappear correct
now we spoke about Matthew 24 quite a
lot and we can to some very interesting
types one or two things didn't you say
some people had a problem with the
abomination of desolation race I've got
there was some comments on that
and yeah tear it up a little bit yeah
let's just have a look here I have some
interesting stuff here in Matthew 24 you
have all the signs of the end now we've
dealt with that quite considerably in
Matthew 24 from verse 15 remember that
it said when ye therefore shall see the
abomination of desolation spoken of by
Daniel the prophet stand in the Holy
Place whosoever readeth let him
understand and we explained that this if
you take the parallel text in in Luke
let this represented the Roman armies in
the Holy Place now what is the Holy
Place mean did it mean the first
compartment of the sanctuary which was
the holy place or well that's not where
the Roman army stood right according to
Luke yes but for a number of felons
outside the city was also regarded as a
holy place so when you see the armies
surrounding and standing in this holy
place with their pagan standard coming
to destroy Jerusalem then you must flee
now when you continue this it says then
you must get out of the cities and we
spoke about you know Titus
second seeds and sisters first seed and
what happened now this is also of course
a story about the end and it says in
verse 22 and except those days should be
shortened there should no flesh be saved
but for the elects sake sake those days
shall be shortened and then it was about
the false comings of Christ and says if
you hear Christ is here or there we
spoke about those issues and then he
says no the coming of Christ will be
universally visible like lightening for
example for as the Lightning comes out
of the east and shineth even unto the
West so shall also the coming of the Son
of Man be but it will also be
universally audible
yes it will be universally visible and
it's fascinating and then this
fascinating verse in the King James
Version Matthew 24 verse 28 wherever the
carcass is there will the eagle's be
gathered together now you know that
doesn't make you really much sense when
you look at it like this because Eagles
don't gather around caucuses correct
correct so the modern translations
actually shall we say in adverted commas
try to correct it and if you take the
NIV for example it says wherever there
is a carcass there the vultures will
gather so they put vultures in the place
of eagles nice the King James wrong then
what it did the translators of the
modern versions perhaps misses something
what are we talking about before what
are we talking about the Roman armies
surrounding Jerusalem this pagan
Standard standing in the holy place in
other words the dictates of paganism
being enforced upon God's people etc
and if you go to this word Eagles it's a
toss you find it in if you go to the
concordances and Thayer has an
interesting one it says an eagle but
then he qualifies it because it's
complicated and he says since Eagles do
not usually go in quest of carrion this
may refer to a vulture that resembles an
ego trash qualified yeah I've seldom
seen a vulture that resembles an ego
except perhaps in flight you can say wow
is that an eagle oh is that a vulture
but then he has a second example and he
says to an eagle as a standard for Roman
military and I believe that that is what
the real issue is so the ego was the
standard of the Roman military if you go
to Wesley's comment it says in Matthew 2
about Matthew 24 28 Wesley wrote the
following for wherever the carcass is
there will the eagle's be gathered
together so I obviously use the received
text right the King James there our Lord
gives this as a further reason why they
should not hearken to any pretended
deliverer so there's a false religion
and true religion he thinks onto the
verses if you hear Jesus is they don't
go out correct as if he had said expect
not any deliverer of the Jewish nation
for it is devoted to destruction it is
already before God a dead carcass which
the wrong Eagles will soon the vows so
he understood it that way he understood
that this abomination of desolation was
the Roman standard and the standard of
the Romans was the eagle
now if you go to the book of Revelation
then you will find that there will be a
second beast that will do the dictates
of the first beast in other words the
second one that does the dictates of of
Rome and we studied that in two beasts
become friends and it is Protestant
United States of America what is their
symbol the eagle and just an interesting
point so yes there was an issue and then
immediately after the tribulation of
that time referring to the Middle Ages
you will have other signs of the coming
of the law and then in verse 32 he says
now learn a parable of the fig tree and
the fig tree was an example of the
Jewish nation right of use of Israel but
when his branch is yet tender and
putteth forth leaves you know that the
summer is nice so likewise when you see
all these things know that it is near
even at the door so we discussed all of
those verses and we discussed the signs
of the times and that's what we've been
focusing on yes and I think we should
move on to Matthew chapter 25 and
Matthew 25 starts with a parable of the
virgins then shall the Kingdom of Heaven
be likened unto ten virgins which took
their lamps and went forth to meet the
bridegroom oh this is such a famous
parable and it's strange that it comes
immediately after Matthew 24 now we've
already looked at Matthew 22
the robe of righteousness now
what preparations did these virgins have
to make and I know that Matthew 25 the
parable of the virgins refers
particularly to the time of the close of
the 2300 day prophecy and but it it is a
it is actually also a timeless
prophecies because in every stage of
human history God's people had sleeping
virgins you know and it'll be no
different at the end Eve so even though
there was a very particular application
at one stage there will be a application
at the end yes now I think we should
discuss Matthew 25 because this is the
preparation for God's people and seeing
that people want to know you know what
must be doing the time that we are
living in then shall the Kingdom of
Heaven be likened unto ten virgins you
know God is a God also of numbers and
numerology
yes which took their lamps and went
forth to meet the bridegroom so there
were ten virgins that means they had not
defiled themselves right yes they had
not defiled themselves with the ways of
the world that had drunken the wine of
Babylon they were they were in tune with
God there were virgins now something
else comes to mind this number ten where
do we find the number ten the 10
commandments what are the attributes of
God's lost church they will keep 13 come
on they will keep the commandments of
God right so here are 10 virgins and
they took their lamps now what is the
what is the lamp thy word is a lamp unto
my feet correct so they they had the
word
and they went forth to meet the
bridegroom
now there's another little parable in in
Luke we read about the parable of the
lost coins yes and there were also 10
Muslim and one of them was lost and it's
interesting it says there what woman
having ten pieces of silver now it's
always interesting to look at these
parables because a woman in the Bible is
a church is a church right having 10
pieces of silver in other words 10
precious something is if she lose one
could you lose a commandment yeah you
could does not light the candle so here
does that mean section scriptures yes
right yes you're gonna search the
Scriptures because the candle is the
light and the light is the word so if
you've lost something don't find it
Deloitte
that's what it means and then sweep her
house what's the house Church it's the
church so if a church has lost something
of value that comes from the Word of God
then she has to search the Scriptures to
find it and if she finds it well in
order to find it you have to first sweep
the house dry so she sweeps the house
and seek diligently till she find it and
when she has found that she calls her
friends and her neighbors what does that
mean the other churches you will do some
evangelism around churches other people
so isn't it surprising that we have
discovered that the law of God is
binding right the ten commandments the
ten precepts are precious and the
commission is go ye into all the world
preach the gospel baptizing and teaching
in other words talk about the precepts
call the friends and the neighbors or
they're all going to be excited no
unfortunately not no saying rejoice with
me yes for I have found the peace which
I had lost Wow beautiful it's beautiful
likewise I said to you there is joy in
the presence of the angels of God over
one sinner that repenteth the wages of
sin is death we spoke about that sin by
definition is what transgression of the
law
transgression of the law that's what
John writes right in his epistles so
here you have the full package so with
this in mind and we know what the lamps
are let's read on with the Virgin's so
they took their lamps and as you said
Psalms 119 verse 105 thy word is a lamp
unto my feet and a light unto my path
and it says that in verse two and five
of them were wise and five were foolish
now these are all in the churchyard
they're all virgins they that were
foolish took their lamps two Bibles they
have the Word of God these and they took
no oil with them oil is a symbol of the
early spirit why don't you give this
Bible no no I think you should start
sitting here and I'll sit over there but
the wise took oil in their vessels with
their lamps so what does that mean no
think you have to help me now we are
vessels as the Bible either for good or
for bad and it's up to God to determine
what this vessel is going to do
so how do I get oil into this vessel if
I'm the vessel I have to internalize the
oil right correct that means I must
allow the Holy Spirit to make the truths
part of my being
yes the it says they they took their
lamps and took no oil so that part is
you've taken the word they had the word
but they hadn't internalizing to analyze
it so the vessel couldn't internalize
the word because it didn't let the Holy
Spirit do the working correct
so you know I can now everything about
this Bible my father-in-law it was such
a brilliant man and if anybody knows
about my testimony was an occultist and
he studied this Bible day night dare not
he was absolutely involved in every
verse but he interpreted everything from
an esoteric direction had no idea about
the plan of salvation in fact it was
totally turned upside down and only
towards the end of his life did
something click and I really hope I will
see him again one day I'd love to talk
to him
so five were wise and five were foolish
and those that didn't internalize the
word make it part of themselves not just
pay lip service to it but actually live
it out and allow this vessel to be
changed you know if you take proverbs 25
verse four it says take away the dross
from the silver and there shall come
forth a vessel for the finer Wow that'd
be beautiful so you're taking away this
dross that which is wrong in your life
your your anger we have we have these
inherited
tendencies now God is going to look at
you and say oh you have inherited
tendencies I'm gonna chop you right off
right then I wouldn't be sitting here no
it's gonna work with you and if you have
a particular tendency which might be
abrasive and you know some people might
say well this person has no chance
whatsoever yes God takes those
circumstances into account he takes your
inherited tendencies into a comment it
is not how often you fall it's how often
you get up that makes the difference so
yes I have a lot of dross inside of me
and many people preach perfectionism
perfectionism is a striving to do what
is right and only within my sphere
within the my capacity I have to do what
is right but always there is this
covering of God His righteousness and
he's working in my heart so you know a
person can be very fiery you're quite a
fiery young man what you look like good
tendencies and then I've got some brakes
as well
yeah bits off is the brakes you know
better half of the bridge the brakes
well it's amazing you know Luther you
also had some breaks in his
relationships Melancon walkways breaks
theologically speaking and his wife had
such beautiful attributes he skated I
love the story about what Luther and his
kata yeah the story when he was
depressed and he sat in the chair
do you know that's thing I can recall it
but you can tell it to us and she put on
black clothes and black veil and it was
two weeks or something she walked around
the house with a black
and black clothes until he finally
noticed in his depression and he said
black died and she says I'm in mourning
who died and she said God died and then
she said but you act like this dead yeah
sorry gave him an object lesson so God
has his ways of dealing with our
inherited tendencies and I just like to
say something when you have if you've
been mentioning now the timber but maybe
if you are asking God to help me with my
temper situation he's not gonna take it
away he's gonna you're gonna probably
get into more situations where that
timber is tasted and that's where he
comes in he's then me to help you to get
to work on it and and you have to you
have to work on it you have to say I
don't want this load and then when it
pops up does that mean the guillotines
come down and you lost no through it
again and again and again and this is
called sanctification it's a process so
God doesn't leave you alone and every
stage is like a father my son now has a
baby as a toddler is one year old and is
actually starting to walk and the great
excitement when it takes three little
steps you know three pathetic little
steps that's how God is exactly exactly
and so as you grow you will of course
have better steps and it starts
immediately yes it's not that you asked
like you said earlier you have to have
four years two weeks five weeks
immediately when you ask God you're in
that relationship from the moment you
say I wanted
and I don't want these tendencies I mean
if you are abrasive now fortunately I've
never been a bracelet in my entire life
I'm perfect if you see that tear running
down someone you're really careful cheek
and you think to yourself why am I such
a idiot yeah and then you ask God to
help you with it and you know that's how
it works okay now let's go to verse five
while the bridegroom tarried hmm where
is it you know what happened they all
slumbered and slip that is very strange
they all slumbered and slept in other
words nobody was really ready for the
announcement and at midnight the darkest
hour of world's history there was a cry
behold the bridegroom cometh go ye out
to meet him then all those virgins arose
and trimmed their lamps and they went
what what's going on where why is the
winner coming you know it said so
something must wake them up and say you
know what time the Lord's coming and
they run backwards and forwards through
the Word of God they trimmed their lamps
they all went to the word to see what is
going on and the foolish said unto the
wise give us your oil for our lamps are
gone out that's a very sad story he said
that's a very sad statement now the wise
answered saying not so lest there be not
enough for us and you are they being
selfish no you sure I think they just
state you cannot impart to others what
is not what is part of you it's
something that should have happened in
their lives they should have studied the
they should have internalized the truth
and their lives should have been or at
least an attempt should have been made
to come into harmony with God's Word and
to internalize that truth now what if
you like me I was an atheist why do you
call the close of probation somebody
tells me something about the Word of God
hmm wow I was wrong all my life and I
don't have large you know huge amounts
of time to go and do this if I honestly
say whoa I was wrong
Lord forgive me well have you rejected
no no so what does it mean when I settle
so leagues on again to the thief on the
cross that's right he could he didn't
have time to go in trim his lab he
didn't have time now this but he made a
decision yes I want to be like that
right now so I don't reach an earlier
you must realize with who's the virgins
correct and we have to ask ourselves the
question why had their lamps gone up yes
the problem with them is that they had
so conditioned themselves in this notion
that this wasn't going to happen in
their lifetime number one and they had
consistently not internalized what the
Holy Spirit had taught them in other
words they never incorporated it into
their life so they have had because they
were virgins all of this time to allow
God to remove the dross but they were
just paying lip service to them to the
word they were saying well this is not
important for me now and this is not
important for me whenever and so it was
to lie to them because they had become
so conditioned in rejecting
the little prods of the Holy Spirit into
a particular direction let's say God
convicts you in the word that your body
is the temple of the Holy Spirit yes and
you caught you've had these
opportunities and consistently you have
resisted them then you run out of oil
yes because the Holy Spirit will say
well I told you but you won't listen
whereas a man who comes in from atheism
is the biggest drunkard that you've ever
seen under the planet and suddenly
realize whoa I was wrong and ask for
forgiveness he hasn't been conditioned
like them and the time of ignorance God
winked at and he can actually take the
place of a virgin that's quite the
stylist very you know so those are
really important points the wise
answered not so can't give you the oil
the food is said to the wise give us
your oil for our lamps have gone out
though I said not so lest there be not
enough for us and you but go rather to
them that sell and buy for yourselves go
buy that's interesting yes where do you
buy what store do you go to
what about Simon Magus yes Simon Magus
what did the shortcut he wanted the
power without the conversion he said
give it to me I'll buy it your money
perish with you but where can you buy
revelation chapter three and this is the
counsel to the Lord see in church this
is the last Church I counsel thee to buy
from me gold tried in the fire and
that's that's amazing that there mayst
be rich and the white raiment there you
have the drop of righteousness that thou
mayst be clothed and that the shame of
thy nakedness do not appear and anoint
thine
is with I solve that thou mayst see so
you are counseled to buy gold gold is
character and when you don't buy it
tried in the fire in other words through
the fire of affliction is there time for
the virgins to achieve that no there's
no time there's no time now what about
that atheist who comes in at the last
minute does he have time no so how do
you witness God looks at the intention
and the resolve and God being
all-knowing knows this person like a
thief on the cross is serious and given
the opportunity you would learn the
lessons yes and got covers it with his
righteousness but the one that has had
the opportunity and consistently
rejected it has proven already that he
is not open to the promptings of the
Holy Spirit and while they went to buy
they tried to get what they neglected to
do remember these are people in the
church we're talking about them now the
bridegroom came and they that were ready
went with him to the marriage and the
door was shut
that's a very sad statement so there was
a close of probation for those virgins
yes they couldn't get it afterwards came
also the other virgins saying Lord Lord
open to us but he answered and said
verily I said to you I know you're not
that must be the worst words that
anybody can hear I stopped them to the
church here so watch therefore for you
know neither the day nor the hour
wherein the Son of man cometh so what is
our duty as Christians now as people in
the church the very
they're not defiled with the wine of
Babylon they are 10 of them they have
all things together they have the whole
Word of God they have all ten coins in
coins in their coffer and five of them
in queue with what they know and five of
them anon and they've had an opportunity
so what is our task now in the light of
this we have to reassess we have to
reassess our lives we have to say this
Christ really coming soon you know
people always think I can pull it off I
can put it off so we have to be in a
state of readiness so just like someone
who comes in from the outside I can do
the same even if I'm in the church I can
say Lord I have been foolish
I have resisted the products of your
Holy Spirit I pray that you will forgive
me
and bring me into harmony with your word
and God will do it yes but if you have
trained your mind to resist then you are
in trouble so my suggestion would be
that everybody takes a good look at
their relationship with God takes a good
look at the lamp and says Lord I I have
a lot to learn and please forgive me and
let's start again
would God reject such a person no never
never never nobody who has ever come to
him will he turn away when there is to
repentance in the heart I think in
actual fact they will be rejoicing in
heaven exactly that and you know
immediately after that story comes the
story of the
talents and there you have the same
story everybody has different attributes
and how did you put them to use to
further God's kingdom hmm did you say
well I know you were hard taskmaster and
therefore doesn't matter to me I don't
want to be involved so I hid my my
talent in my own family circle my
mother-in-law who was an atheist and she
was always very annoyed with the Bible
and we were sitting and talking after we
were we were always on the same
wavelength because I was an atheist so
she was a wonderful person and very
upright in all the things and very
intelligent professor at the University
and very knowledgeable and she got so
annoyed every time later when we we
accepted Christianity and she said God
is not fair because the story where he
calls people to work in his vineyard and
he makes a day's wages and then he
called some later and then some the 11th
and at the end of the day he gives them
the same wages right she says that
studies so unfair that is
unrighteousness that is it just shows
the character of God it's disgusting and
I looked at her and I said okay you're
thinking in terms of the world you're
thinking in terms of monetary
renumeration for work done the God is
not thinking in terms of that he's
thinking of eternal life the reward for
the work in the vineyard when you are in
tune with us where is eternal life
so are you and a half eternal life for a
quarter eternal life or a fraction
paralyzed you can't the wage is the same
yeah and you can't complain about it and
the same here were the talents so you
have the story here where he that
received two he had gained other two he
that had received one went and digged in
the earth and hid his Lords money and
after a long time the Lord of those
servants cometh and reckon us with him
with them and so he that had received
five talents came and brought under five
talents saying Lord
now the Liveris unto me five talents
behold I have gained beside them five
talents more and his Lord said unto him
well done thou good and faithful servant
enter thou into the joy of the Lord and
the one who had received two talents and
he said you gave me two talents behold I
have gained two other talents and he
said well done ya know I always look at
this story and I think to myself this is
this is astounding do you know who I
have the best rapport with in the church
does that have very few talents they act
from simplicity and not so complicated
they're not so educated that the
education is clouded there their
perspectives they have such simple faith
the Lord said it I believe it
and the Lord's gonna say to them well
done well done and some of them have got
many talents and you have to use them
for the Lord and he'll say well done but
you're not said why your works ever
never
but the other one he hid his talent in
the earth and Lord called him a wicked
and slothful servant so you can you can
have the truth and never use it or you
could be afraid to use it
now the Bible says outside of the
fearful in other words if you are too
afraid too afraid to ever give an
opinion or speak about God's Word and
thereby people are lost because of your
silence some people are afraid of
ridicule right yes and Peter was afraid
of ridicule and he fell now
ridicule is an amazing thing and it's
probably one of the hardest ones to
overcome when I became a believer and I
started teaching or lecturing on
creation versus evolution I got really
cold like you cannot believe as I said
you know this man's been struck by
lightning and he's gone mad some got
very angry if some scientists even spat
in my face I mean it's amazing our angry
people get at these things ridicule is
the hardest one yeah to handle it is
yeah so what is your attitude in other
words to this gospel in verse 29 for
unto every one that has shall be given
and he shall have abundance but from him
that has not shall be taken away even
that which he has and costi the
unprofitable servant into outer darkness
there you have that same sort of issue
so again why must I do if I know this
truth what is my duty to
Jarrid yes it's not my responsibility to
make sure that the other person accepts
it I must just share it and I mustn't be
afraid to say what I believe so do you
think the people will my colleagues for
example my ex colleagues at the
university do you think they will mock
me if I say the Lord made this world in
six days yes so they they were ready to
kill me for believing in a six-day
creation and they were ridiculed me for
believing in a short chronology right
yes do I therefore have to bury my faith
and hide it under a bushel and say to
the Lord one day I knew what the truth
was but I never opened my mouth mystery
oh if I know the truth I have to speak
when he for instance like we mentioned
in a previous episode I also wasn't an
Adventist seventh-day Adventist all my
life so when these truths and these
things started coming towards us and we
accepted it and we were excited I think
if I just think back that William Miller
and those people that thought that these
beautiful truths coming to them now
wanted to share it to everybody and they
thought that the churches will embrace
this and that if met the Lord is coming
the same that I embraced it the Lord
wants us to have a special time with him
on his day it hasn't changed
so I want everybody to know this
beautiful thing and you can up against
the brick wall you and I think you will
up until when the Lord actually comes in
the clouds but nevertheless you told
your friends so when you found that coin
that lost coin and you'd swept your
house and you went to your friends and
your neighbors and you said hey I've
discovered my coin here I want to share
this with you what was the result
yeah not the same excitement not the
same excitement
so but you said it now what have you
said I'm gonna keep this to myself
because what's the point it wouldn't
have been beneficial to anyone right and
afterwards when you do actually get the
ridicule it's harder to then keep on
going yes that's important as well
don't stop once every cue comes so the
Word of God is the standard it's the
standard of righteousness when you
discover a truth then you must ask God
to write it on the tablets of your heart
and you must be able to stand by it and
you know God is gracious he doesn't
expect blind faith he wants you to have
an informed faith so when I started
asking the question I'm overwhelmed
because all of my scientific education
tells me that this is contrary to
everything that I stand for and believe
I'm not going to be able to just switch
without the necessary information to
base my decision on he was gracious and
he gave it to me I went all over the
world and I discovered all of these
amazing examples of a totally different
world view on creation and geology and
I'm not gonna give up lecture now but
then we come to the final judgement in
Matthew 25 when the Son of man shall
come in his glory
what is his glory his character it's his
character that shines for this merciful
loving God everything you read in Exodus
yes comes in in that glory comes and all
the holy angels with him then shall he
sit upon the throne of his glory and
before him shall be gathered all nations
and he shall separate them one from
another as a shepherd divideth his sheep
from the
goats so they welcome a ton of judgment
and he shall set the sheep on his right
hand but the goats on his left then
shall the King say unto them on his
right hand come ye blessed of my father
inherit the kingdom prepared for you
from the foundations of the world
mazing promise now what is your concept
of heaven mine yeah because if you have
a concept of heaven like most of the
world like I had you know we're gonna
sit on cloud nine and you're gonna go
blessed from your heart you're right
and you better be light enough or else
you're gonna fall through that cloud
I must admit previously you didn't have
a very clear picture of heaven and one
picture that actually comes to mind now
is one that the movies creates for you
uh-huh and that will be that once you
die you make it meet your relatives and
all of this so there was a nice aspect
to it but that was telling you that
immediately after you die so that lived
out the part that the judgment is and
there will be a death in the
resurrection now what what I found
amazing is that you have a physical
resurrection you're called forth from
the grave and you get a glorified body
now what does that mean a glorified body
the Bible says like unto his glorified
body
now what did Jesus do when he had a
glorified body after the resurrection he
stood in the middle of the room and all
the doors were closed how do you get in
there yeah and yet it was physical as
you said come and touch me yeah come and
do this give me something to eat yeah
I'm a human being I'm not a ghost
so what are the capacities of those that
body it must be amazing and I think
we've talked about some of these things
before
the eye has not seen nor ear has heard
the wonders that God has prepared for
them that love him the the city were the
gold streets transparent gold that
beautiful Garden of Eden incited those
beautiful rivers everybody I go to
prepare a place for you and my father's
house are many mansions if it were not
so I would have told you and then in the
earth made new you will plant vineyards
and you will eat of them you'll no
longer be driven off your land by
circumstances or pain or death and you
will discover the wonders of the
universe I just imagined true education
yes we are so overwhelmed with lies in
this world what is truth you have to
search for it as for a hidden treasure
imagine if all truth is open to your
investigation imagine if you can look at
a plant and you have x-ray vision and
you have all the spectrum and you can
see into it and you can see past it and
you your your vision will have all the
capacities that God has given for
example in ego we were speaking about
evening flying up there kilometers in
the air and he sees a mouths rustling
that you cannot even see standing next
to every face can you imagine having
that kind of vision can you imagine
seeing how true violet can you imagine
seeing x-ray vision going right into
something and studying the workings and
the mechanism of everything the
capacities that you will have in an
unfallen brain you know God is amazing
because every now and then he gives us a
hint and normally it is someone that has
a little bit of brain damage
like autism or I know what is that guy's
name that knows all the encyclopedias
off by heart and it's an amazing story
and terry has total recall here readable
like this has some total recall of
everything like a photograph and it will
give it to you or somebody who has to
compute a mathematical equation you have
these super cases okay yeah and they're
just rattle off a calculation to the
umpteenth decimal point I mean it's just
unbelievable that's the kind of capacity
you will have so there are possibilities
in your brain that we cannot even think
of and then you will be able to see all
the unseen worlds and you'll have the
capacity to move between the dimensions
between the seen and the unseen it'll be
an amazing world and just think of the
knowledge that you'll be able to gain
and people say no I don't want to go my
first one to finish my my education here
what miss out on the greatest university
that exists in the entire universe where
the greatest teacher that has ever
exists there I mean it's just
unbelievable that people would want to
cling to this darkness when that light
and those capacities will be available
to you and everything you do will be
successful yes
amazing yes I like to both you know and
it says you will build houses and you
will not build and others inhabit them
you're not going to be disinherited of
your land you're not going to be chucked
out of your house you don't have to put
a lock on your door and no locks no
nothing you don't need a car even
because you want to be somewhere you'll
be there instantly take examples in the
Bible they were rowing right Jesus was
in the boat Anna miracle had taken place
the next instant they were on the shore
okay Philip he's talking to the
Ethiopian he appears in the desert gets
onto that wagon gives him a bottle study
the next instant he's in a town
kilometers away yeah what is that movie
okay no tiresome drive forever and ever
so let's say you you need help from God
and you pray lord help me and he sends
an angel from heaven and it's gonna take
three weeks for him to get there that's
a little bit of light right instantly
before you prayed says the Bible I heard
before you prayed and that's that kind
of communication with God yes
can you imagine sitting at the feet of
God looking into the face that's what I
wanted to get that also for me Moses how
was his face lit up and he was in a
cloud and he couldn't even see God face
to face no it was in a cloud and he was
shining so that the others couldn't look
at him
so he must have been like the Sun right
so he had to veil his face imagine
looking into the unobstructed face of
God and getting real information and
going on state visits with God it's just
amazing and then this is what will
happen
he says enter in inherit the kingdom
prepared for you from the foundations of
the world
God wants every single one to be saved
yes he's not a god that's tyrannical for
I was hungered and he gave me meat and I
was thirsty and you gave me drink I was
a stranger and you took me in like it
you clothed me I was sick you visited me
I was in prison and you came unto me
then shall the righteous answer them and
say when we saw the a hundred
fed thee or thirsty and gave you the
drink when we saw this stranger and took
the in or naked and clothed these all
question marks when we saw these
stranger no read that or when we saw
these sick when present when did that
happen I don't know and the King shall
answer and said unto them verily I said
to you in as much as you have done it
unto the least of these my brethren
you've done it unto me that's
Christianity an act of kindness here a
word of encouragement there that's what
that's what Christianity is all about a
kind word at the right time or sometimes
no word just saved here
that's what humanity needs and that's
what we need to be there are too many
Christians in the world that are so
judgmental that they always have the
standard that you must meet and they
have the skillet in God concept we need
to set the world straight on the
character of God how was Jesus when he
dealt with the rest of them wasn't he
always kindness but he was also just he
said go and sin no more
and how did you I just want to also say
he treated those people with kindness
and everything and then you can see the
side of his right shoe though of his is
righteous indignation yes yes and it's
also not unloving no but it's setting
him straight for the people that should
have known it absolutely god never does
anything that doesn't inter love even
even the destruction of the wicked is an
act of mercy
because they would forever be unhappy
number one and they would forever create
unhappiness and God doesn't want that
when he said the day you eat of it you
will surely die it is the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil now God never
intended anyone to have the knowledge of
evil he never wanted the mother to stand
at the grave of a child he never wanted
that pain that evil brings but now that
we have a knowledge of evil it can be an
inoculant and I would say the whole
world needs this vaccinations just
explain that not the one this
vaccination against this virus called
sin is an inoculant that every single
person needs to safeguard heaven I'm
more afraid of this thing called sin in
my system than I am of any virus in any
case it can only kill me temporarily if
I am in Christ so let us work at
internalizing God's truth while we have
the opportunity there does not be
hoarders of God's truth let its data
share it sometimes there will be a
backlash Jesus was crucified as a
consequence of sharing the Word of God
but he looked into the future and he
looked at the joy from an eternity
aspect and we should have the same we
should be like Jesus we should be able
to look past the attributes in the
character of others that caused pain yes
so you know if you see someone with five
nose rings
50 chickering's tattoos all over what's
your attitude gonna be are you gonna say
look at that or are you going to say
that person is giving a cry for help and
if you see it like that and you treat
them with kindness then that is doing it
unto others as you would like as you
would have done it to him and God sees
that and I had a man asked me once he
was tattooed from top to bottom and he
asked me so and we're now out of the
equation because I have all of these
tubes tattoos and I said to him you know
some people carry the scars of this
world on the inside and some people
carry the scars of this world on the
outside what's the difference that's
beautiful
what happens is what is your
relationship with God yes and that is my
encouragement to the viewers when we're
talking about all of these things and
the coming of Christ whatever you do
don't lose sight of the character of God
and don't lose sight of the fact that he
is a loving father that you can approach
at any time no matter what your
circumstance or however bad the thing is
that has occurred in your life with him
there is an abundance of forgiveness
so come to you to the Heavenly Father
confess to him your problem repent and
receive a spotless robe of righteousness
I mean did you pray for us please
Heavenly Father there are always two
sides of the story there is a war but
there is also a victory there's an
internal war and with you at the helm
they can be victory and so I pray Lord
that you will lead your people into a
relationship with you where we do not
kick against the pricks of the Holy
Spirit but where we embrace them help us
to have oil in our vessels in Jesus name
Amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time